team is the new bright flow cytometry
panel design within vitrogen nova 4 dies
i'm dr anson blanks of thermo fisher
scientific and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific to learn
more please visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type your questions into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
speaker catherine friend business
development nova floor dies at thermo
fisher scientific
hi there thank you very much
the time of my talks today is clean as
the new bride so today i'm going to be
looking through and talking about flow
cytometry panel design
in particular we're using the
in-vitrogen overflow dyes and we'll be
looking also at utilizing the demo
fisher panel builder as well to
incorporate number floor dyes into into
the panels
so
if we're looking at optimal panel design
um particularly if we're looking at it
from a fluorophore perspective we really
need to look at say four different um
different considerations so the first
the spectral overlap
where you know you have to look at the
the fluorescence spectra itself and see
where it overlaps into other
into other
detectors
the second is antigen density where
we're looking at how
many antigens are there either on the
cell surfa sorry how many antigens of
the cell of the marker of interest is
actually there within your sample and
therefore this will really um play a big
part as to
which fluorophore you um you assign to
that particular antigen
the third is
spillover and spreading and obviously
every fluorophore has
some kind of level of spillover and
spreading and we need to take that into
consideration and the fourth is stain or
separation index and this obviously um
can it needs to be a consideration
because it um
affects the brightness or the brightness
of i mean it really shows the brightness
of the fluorophore and that again is
really important in terms of panel
design
being able to balance your panels
properly
um by matching your antigen density with
your fluorescent brightness
so i'm going to go into each one of
these and then i'm going to go and look
at nova floors and how they can be
incorporated into into your current
panels and how you can create new panels
with nova floors
so let's look at spectra overlap so this
occurs when a fluorophores fluorescence
it spills over into the detection of
another fluorophore so there are many
fluorophores in fact most fluorophores
all fluorophores have some kind of
spillover
many of them have quite a broad emission
or they're excited by multiple lasers
and each one of these causes spectral
overlap and needs to be considered in
your panel design
antigen density and in fact i'll go into
a little bit more detail with antigen
density than spectral
overlap at the moment so antigen density
refers to the number of target molecules
expressed on a given cell
so your antigen density really needs to
be considered in every single panel
design and in fact this is one of the
tricky things that um i have encountered
in making kind of panels
um the reason is
is that antidensity can vary depending
on your cell type your disease condition
your drug treatment
or whatever treatment you happen to be
putting onto your samples your sample
preparation and your certain activation
states of your obvious of your cells
and so
these need to be
again considered
in terms of panel design
the best way that we've found to be able
to determine antigen density apart from
testing it yourself
is to review your recent available
literature regarding your cell type and
your antigen of interest and again if
that's not available you're going to
have to test yourself
um the other
way to look uh to kind of determine
energy and density without testing
itself is to look at other um
other available resources there's two
that i can suggest at the moment they're
really quite helpful
omits or optimized multi-color multi
immunofluorescence panels
uh special peer-reviewed cytometry part
a open access publications
and they basically outline a number of
different panels that have been designed
and tested and work and so they're
really good resource if you're wanting
some some place to start
there's also um city maps
um
city maps are available i've given an
article a website here that's available
from the hcdm
they're um it's basically mapped the
expression or the general expression of
human city one to a hundred on
particular immune cell subsets and so
these are really quite interesting
some of the um there are some of the
other
companies tend to have
a couple of documents on antigen density
but i found that um
these again because
this varies substantially on cell type
and sample preparation
these aren't always exhaustive and so
i would always use a number of different
factors to determine the antidensity of
your particular sample type
so
let's talk about antigen density though
because that really affects how you set
up your panel okay so let's start with
these low antenna expression level
markers these ones who are low or you
don't even know what their expression is
like
often times for these markers you can
see if their antigen density is is
low
based or low or or minimal based on the
amount of fluorophores that are
available in the
market on these particular markets
um
i'll also show a little uh some some
data later where you can actually use
the market available
information to really determine whether
your antigen
will
determine what your antigen density is
going to possibly be like in your sample
but either way
these
these low antigen
density markers
really
have poor expression their populations
may be smaller but what you need to do
is save your brightest fluorophores for
these and i would always assign these
first you want to make sure that in any
given panel you're actually looking at
these particular markets because they're
often the critical target in the panel
next what i would also look at is these
high antigen expression levels the the
high antigen density markers
and these are the ones that i'm actually
in panel design are assigning a lot of
the nova floors to because now before
depending on the naval floor can be
quite dim and so in a paddle design
what you want to be doing is you want to
be balancing out your antigen
levels with your fluorophore brightness
you don't want a whole stack of bright
flaws because that is going to you know
you because your antigen levels will
vary and so you really need to be able
to match these
so again i would find that these high
antigen expression level markers
they're often well characterized they
usually can identify quite broad subsets
of cells they're usually your lineage
markers um the expression is either
positive or negative so really easily
easily defined
and they can often be used as the parent
gate and so you would assign
these to the demo fluorophores or the
targets that are most affected by this
philosophy but i spill over
so
after you've done that so you've got
you've assigned your low antigen
expression
markers to your
um really bright fluorophores you've
excited your
your really high antigen expression
markers to your really low fluorophores
then you've got everything else and then
you just need to again match up your
expression levels with fluorophore
brightness and that's more of
i mean a lot of times it's also about
what's available by that studies as well
so
um
yeah it's a so it's a kind of a
this is you know filling in the gaps as
well in your panel
so as i said beforehand you can use
what's available in the marketplace um
from all these different companies to
actually determine the level of antigen
brightness that you need
the
to kind of look at the antigen
brightness
of a particular marker on a particular
cell type or the relative one so for
instance this is cd4
and as you can see this city four
conjugates can have
three different levels with these three
different conjugates you can have three
different levels of um separation index
depending on the fluorophore that it's
attached to
and so you'll have um for instance if
you're using
34 happens to be in this sample quite
well expressed if you're using a really
high brightness fluorophore like apc
you'll see a really big shift over here
so a really big difference in between
your positive and negative cell
population
whereas
with my dog in the background
this is working from home
um
whereas if for instance you're using a
less bright floor for instance like e450
you will see a smaller shift between
your positive and negative cells
fortunately for cd4
um
this doesn't
matter too much you can still see a
quite a good separation between your
positive and negative cells and i would
suggest if you're looking for
looking to have a look at antigen
density
and you see that
for instance lower
lower brightness fluorophores don't
necessarily separate out your positive
and negative negative cell populations
then i would suggest that this is
a really good way of determining whether
or not you should be using a brighter
floor on those particular
on those particular markers
as well as obviously going back to your
your research on the current
publications as well
so
how we determine brightness there are
two there's two ways that we're used in
the market in the market at the moment
you either use stain index or separation
index
at the moment with maneuver floors the
way that they're set up we actually use
separate separation index because it's
providing a slightly more accurate
measure of fluorophore background
compared to the sustaining index
both of them will just consider the
difference between the positive and
negative
populations
and
what we're trying to define here is just
a
relative
level of fluorophore brightness between
different fluorophores
so we use that
with our never floor
panel design to just to be able to
determine um
the level of brightness of the node
floors as compared to many of the
fluorophores that are around out there
in the marketplace and you'll see that
on the nova floor
landing page on our on the them official
website
so
another consideration
that we have to
well take into consideration is spill
over and spreading so many fluorophores
um
either have this broad emission
structure so for instance here we can
see um the brilliant violet 510 is of
the meeting over a number of different
detectors or you have these cross laser
excitation for instance with pe and the
pe
tandems where these
these dyes are excited by a number of
different lasers
both of these
um
both of these particular
anomalies i would say for fluorophores
will affect the resolution of the entire
panel because what they're doing is
they're spilling over or spreading into
other detectors or other other channels
and as you can see here from laura
johnson's um
blog
so
the apc size 7 is spilling over into the
c size p size seven
and um will need to be compensated to be
to determine um
the real value of the
of the marker that's determined in the
pe si7 channel
this kind of led me to the discussion
about the co-expression of markers and
so
spillover spreading particularly for
co-co-express markets is quite a problem
because you won't be able to determine
the the difference but
the real value of these markets
and so you want to minimize
the spillover of say you're highly
expressed populations this is detectors
that are a little bit more sensitive or
those that have um lower
lower expressed markers
the way you can do this is you need to
space out your fluorophores of
co-expressed markers
across your panel
and if you can place mutually exclusive
markers in adjacent channels that's kind
of the best option for you as well
another way to do this is to use a
fluorophore that has a very dim a very
slim spectra and doesn't spill over
across a number of different detectors
to reduce the um
reduce the splitter
impact on the resolution of this biology
and so this is what we're trying to do
with nova floors is reduce the the
spillover spreading and so increase your
biological resolution
so
if we look at panel design and the
requirements that you need for panel
design
first of all you need to understand your
targets of interest so you need to
really understand first of all your
sample type
um
and obviously all the complete
conditions that your sample is undone
the markers of interest and again i
reiterate that micro abundance or
antigen density is really important as
well
in terms of strategies um you need to
understand your atomic configuration and
also your fluorophore compatibility you
really need to understand how
fluorophores work with dates
you need to have a good gating strategy
and this will determine whether or not
you put
put certain markers in adjacent in
adjacent channels
and then obviously you need to look at
market co-expression again this will
determine whether or not you put things
next to each other in your panel
obviously online resources will help to
to
build your panel
and so this kind of brings me to
introducing overflows
so nova floors are like a a unique
set of dyes
they have um unique spectral signatures
they're designed with this narrow
emission spectrum in mind
they're particularly engineered with
minimal more cross laser excitation and
to decrease the spillover spread
across
across the spectra to increase the
resolution of your panels
they're actually easy to add and to
existing panels and um easy to create
panel panels with nova floors and again
i will go through that um at the moment
and they can be used for conventional
cytometers and for spectral cytometers
as well
so let's look at nova floors what are
they
so they're actually um engineered single
strand dna um
dna dyes so what we do is we engineer
these single stranded dna
um
with a number of fluorophores embedded
in that dna
and so then they anneal into this phyton
structure in the middle here
and this cytostructure holds these
particular fluorophores
in place and so what this means is this
slurophores fret off each other
producing a specific
a specific emission spectra
they're then attached with an oligo
label to um to your antibody yeah
and so what we can do
in fact this is kind of unique
is that we can add extra fluorophores if
needs be and we can actually increase
the brightness and so here on the on the
right hand side you can see um the first
one at the top
is has two is is
uh two labeled phyton or two arm has two
arms are labeled and there's one down
the bottom is has four arms that are
labeled with phytons and this can
actually increase the brightness and so
what we have done is that we've created
two different um
for instance we can and we have created
two different dyes that emit in the same
channel but have different brightnesses
as a result of this kind of this
engineering of the brightness we are
able to do
what's nice about the nova floors
is that using this particular structure
we have now managed to release 19 nova
floors over the last year
and each one of these are um either set
to compete with a dive that is
particularly spectrally promiscuous if
they aren't allowed to use that um in
fact so that it you know it spreads
across a number of different detectors
or that it fills in the spectral space
so you know there is a lot of you know
there's a lot more detectors at the
moment with these current cytometers
then there is dyes and so again we're
starting to fill in some of the special
space that is available at the moment
we're using overflows and so um
the nice thing about nova floors is that
the naming the nomenclature is really
easy you can you basically can see where
it emits based on its name so nova floor
blue 510 for instance the mid
510 off the blue laser
example
the other thing that we've done with
overflow dyes is that we've really tried
to engineer them so that they have quite
a slim spectrum
so that they actually can be used in
adjacent detectors
and if you can see here these are two
dyes number four blue five thirty and
then floor blue five ten um
that's in a spectral cytometer you're
actually able to determine both of them
in a conventional cyto maybe not but um
because their spectra is different
you're actually able to use them
together
um and they're
they and they have like you know minimal
cross laser excitation so you can see
you can see that they um yeah you can
use them together in a panel what this
means is that you can increase the
capacity of your panel
to be able to add more markers
so
i did mention beforehand that you can
engineer the brightness
and what we've done in terms of the
nomenclature is that we've looked at
separation indices
um
comparing cd4 across a number of
different fluorophores on an aurora
um asic aurora and we've found
that um
the best way to determine or to name our
different
fluorophores in terms of brightness is
to just put this separation indices kind
of
figure next to it and so
again this is the relative score but we
found that for instance for another for
ballistics 10 die we have um
one dye that has a separation disease of
30 and another dye that has a separation
indices of about 70 so we um we have
named them note 4 blue 6 10 30 s and 17f
and again what this means is for
instance if somebody is doing a
longitudinal study and they want to test
for a particular marker that changes in
terms of density across that
longitudinal study you can swap out one
floor for another um
in your panel depending on antigen
density so
um which is quite handy i think
um
another kind of anomaly with with nova
floor dyes is that we've found that
they
can
uh non-specifically bind to monocytes
and macrophages in a similar way to
other dyes like europea and apc tandem
dyes do
and so we recommend and we we recommend
that for every nova floor dye you use
the cell blocks monocyte macrophage
blocking buffer
it can be used um
instead of
other macrophage
monocyte blocking buffers that are on
the market at the moment and can also
stop the non-specific binding of
rvp and apc tandems
to macro pudges and on the sides as well
um and we recommend adding them to save
the mark the antibody next mixture just
before you add yourself so
um it's just
is something that we found and we
include uh
we include some uh number
sorry cell blocks with every single nova
floor dye that's sold at the moment
another kind of anomaly for nova floor
dyes is that obviously they're dna based
so you can't use anything that is a dna
binding dye for viability so that
includes say udafi or a7f double led or
pretty my diet we do recommend using um
a main reactive viability diet such as
the in-vitrogen live debt fixable the
same dead cell stains
um
so
what we have available to us is we've
got a list of directly conjugated
lineage markers um
conjugated to all fifths all nineteen
number four dies we also have um a
conjugation kit which is really handy if
you wanted to add an extra marker to
your panel and you and you have no space
to put it we've got 15 19 different
overflows that you can can slot in
wherever you need it to
and so this conjugation kit has a three
easy step process you basically attach
your single stranded dna
no full linker to the antibodies then
you remove your excess linker and attach
the no floor dye and then you anneal the
no floor dye
together
it's a really easy three-step process to
take one to two days to do and not much
hands-on time so
if you need to use this we would highly
recommend this antibody
conjugation kit
so let's look at
adding markers to a panel and this is
the considerations that you need to take
that you need to look at to minimize the
loss of resolution and maximizing your
data integrity so
in any panel design if you add another
panel or sorry if you add another marker
to the panel this is really going to
increase your complexity of the panel
and therefore decrease the possibility
of your
your the resolution
um of your biology
you really need to know your instrument
detectors and understand your dye
spectra um so really important to match
your floral for brightness with your
antigen expression level and obviously
you know that
that
that becomes much more important as you
increase the number of um
number of markers in your panel a really
well balanced panel in terms of antigen
and fluorophore brightness makes such a
difference to your the resolution of
your panel
so
what do naval floors do well we actually
have a number of them that can compare
with the current fluorophores that are
on the marketplace at the moment and if
you have a look these are all the nova
floor blue and yellow dyes that are
comparing competing comparing
competing with um
normal traditional diets like fitsy or
pe
or hpc for instance
um
one thing one caveat i would say is that
the
brightness is not always the same in
terms of node floors but then brighter
is not always better
cleaner is is better than bright at the
moment if you're looking at panel design
and so um you when you are replacing
your um traditional dyes with nova floor
tiles i would really consider the
antigen authority the antigen density
and the brightness as well with your
panel
so let's look into that a little bit
more
um
for instance this is so your p e and p
tandem guys they're excited by a number
of different laces and so what this
means is special spillover across a
number of different laser lines what we
can do is that we can look at pat's
replacing this p that tandem which is p
dazzle
with something
that is spectrally slimmer and doesn't
isn't excited by um
by two different or three different
laser lines so what we've done here is
instead of using pe dazzle we've
actually replaced it with not one little
two nova floors so here you can replace
pier dazzle with nova floor blue 610 and
nova floor yellow 610 which is
especially slimmer and so what this
means is you can get a two for one
upgrade of your panel
the caveat is that
pe dazzle is really quite bright and
neither one of these floors are very are
are as bright as
as the dazzles so you do need to look at
antigen density and where that will work
in your panel to see if you can do this
as well but
saying that it's an easy way of
upgrading your panel and adding extra
extra markers if you wanted to
plus reducing the spillover spread from
pu does was also
handy as well so let's look at how we've
done that
so for instance here we have a
traditional panel on an aurora sorry not
a road my apologies a traditional panel
run on a tube
and here we have like a different 11
different colors
and
if you have a look here at bl2 and yl2
these two detectors can't be used
because bl2 is currently experiencing
the whole experiencing a whole stack of
spillover spread from the whale to
detect channel here
um so the pedestal 594 with cd45ra is
spilling over into the l2 so it can't be
used
conversely the whale 2
um whatsoever whale 3
psi 5 5.5
um
possibly could be used in this detector
however it is receiving a whole heap of
spillover spread from the bl3
um channel here so from first a piece of
iphone 5.5 is spilling over and
spreading into whale three so we're not
using a particular marker in there
because that would affect the resolution
what we can do
is that we can replace these
we can replace first dpsi five point
five and p dazzles 5.94 with nova 4's
and by doing that we actually open up
two extra detectors to be able to use
them so what we've done is we've added
an extra couple of markers in here so as
well as replacing kind of direct
directly
replacement dies insert so for instance
alexa floor 488 can be replaced by nova
floor blue 530
um we've actually
added we've replaced not only we've
replaced those those dies we've also
added an extra couple of those as well
so we've added
cxcr4 and cd28 into this panel as well
now what does that do
it gives us a little bit more resolution
and greater depth
so in fact now we're actually able
better able to
resolve our naive t cells our central
memory t cells and our effective memory
t cells as a result of these adding
these extra two markers to the to your
panel
what we've also done though and this is
really quite subtle but very important
and it actually becomes more important
the more
the more markers you have or the bigger
the panel is
is that
um i know this is quite small you
probably can't see it that well but
across the spectra by taking p dazzle
out of this particular panel
right across the spectra we have reduced
a whole
heap of spillover
across a number of different
detectors
ideally what was what this will do
is um
increase the resolution of those
particular markers in each one of those
detectors so by
taking pedestal out of this particular
panel we have increased the resolution
of the entire panel and so
this is again what we're trying to show
here with nova floors is that they can
be used to
increase your balance biological
resolution of your panel
so optimizing panel design
one really good um way of looking at
your panels is to look at your spillover
spread matrix after you've after you've
run it down something like flojo and you
can identify
using this spillover spreader matrix
those dies that are adding most to
spread across your panel these ones are
the ones that we'd probably be wanting
to take out of your your
your current panel and replace with
something slimmer in terms of spectra
like as an overflow die
you want to also identify the available
detectors that you've got availa
available to you so
times you will have particularly with
these nova floor dyes that are um able
to slot into spectral spaces that
weren't
that didn't have any other dyes in them
beforehand
identify those available detectors and
then um you can you can see what else
you can add to the panel
um
you want to replace these high spreading
dies that obviously you've identified in
your ssm
analysis with your anova floor dyes or
any other alternative diet that has less
spreading than these high spreading
diets
but again the caveat is that you want to
consider quite carefully the level of
antigen density in replacing these dyes
not every dye is the same and you need
to consider this quite carefully
what you could do though is either
replace it directly with an overflow or
you can swap your markers around again
to balance the antigen expression with
dye brightness for these panel designs
so next i want to look at building a
panel from scratch and for this i wanted
to look at the panel builder that
the invitation flow cytometry panel
builder that's available online i looked
at this demo official website
so
um
this
i've used a number of different panel
builders in fact i think i've used most
of them that are on the marketplace and
i really think i mean i'm not being
biased but i really think that this is
the best one and i'll tell you why
um it's
what it does is it allows you to add any
kind of configuration of your cytometer
and the nice thing about it is that it
will list the fluorophores in
or sorry list the
the products in terms of
this muscle that's the antibodies that
you're putting in there in terms of
product availability and so at least the
ones that have less
um
less available direct conjugates first
which is the ones that you want to
assign because they're the ones that you
can never find any
any available
um direct conjugates to so
i think this is a really great panel um
panel design tool to do this
so what do we do first
um going into the
the panel builder
first of all you can select your
subterminal and we've got a
hopefully when we're listing most if not
all of the cytometers that are on the
market at the moment
alternatively you can actually
customize your cytometer setting
using the tab down the bottom there
so
first of all you need to just sit there
and set up the panel builder to your
flow statometer configurations
um and the settings can be saved and
there is again an extensive list of
conventional or spectral instruments
that's on there at the moment
and you can use the
you can use this to
change or modify the cytometer
information and you need to make sure
that the filter settings on the
particular cytometer that you've chosen
actually match those that you have
that you're going to use so
um
so then the next step really is to
select your antibodies your proteins and
reagents
so
initially like this is the next step of
the panel builder first of all you you
can put in the antibodies that you
already have in your panel
the next step is to add any fluorescent
proteins things like gfp
or rfp or any other proteins that you're
um you're using within the panel
then
the next step obviously the one of the
most important is to add all the markers
in that you need
and for this it'll actually show you you
can
add in the antibodies
and you can add in the antigen density
as well of these antibodies which is
really quite handy
and then
you can the final step is to add in any
extra non-antibody reagents things like
your cell viability of your protein your
functional protein um diets or your cell
cycle analysis diets and other things
like that
next you um
you know
again this would the the view from this
point on depends on whether you've
chosen a conventional cytometer or a
respectful certain they they have
different views so first i'm going to
talk about conventional cytometers
to start off with you have this um once
you've got everything in there including
all of your your different markers it'll
show you this matrix view of
your column your channels at the top
here and your antigens listed along the
rows
each one of these colored dots
will
indicate a particular
a particular fluorochrome that is
available in each particular channel and
so
each one of these basically indicates a
product that is available in particular
fluorochrome that can be detected within
that detector
the nice thing about it though is that
um oh yeah sorry the black flags will
indicate your recommended channels and
these will decrease depending on how
many you choose and as it as you two as
you go through and and highlight
each one of those
um
you want to highlight the particular
product that you're going to be using
these will gray out and so you can't
then
you can't then pick something that will
be detected in the same in the same
detector
um so the recommendations the black
flags for these will be based on first
of all your protein abundance from the
antigen slider and the fluorochrome
brand abundance and they will look at
the antigen brightness and so the
antigen density and the fluorochrome
brightness in terms of being able to
recommend the right product for that for
that particular marker
um in a special certainty too you have a
different view
um
and so
here you still see the the channels and
the antigens in this matrix view but you
also get this kind of thing this
complexity score and so as you're going
through
um picking your fluorochrome this is
using a drop down manual um it'll
increase the the complexity will
increase
and so
maybe i'll show a bit better on them on
the next page
um
if you pick a fluorophore that is going
to compete directly with another floral
it increases the complexity incredibly
you will get this this kind of orange
flag
and so i would always concede about
suggesting another fluorophore and as
you see so long when you're when you're
picking these fluorophores you need to
just um there's a drop down menu
and what's nice about this is it'll show
a complexity score um for the addition
of each of these um
of of each fluorophore that you've got
available to you and so it'll also show
in the top right corner a combined
complexity score and so
obviously you want to make sure the
complexity of your panel is as minimal
as possible
um
because this will this will add to the
you know
a lower complexity score will increase
your resolution
final selection
um
is
uh when you you know when you finally
decide on the on the antigen that you
want
um
you basically click on it and you can
see a whole heap of detailed information
on that particular antigen that's
available also that particular product
that's available as well
the nice thing about it then is once
you've selected your clone you can have
a look at it in a bit more detail
as well
the final point of your um
of of the thermo fischer panel builder
is that
you can then export any of these lists
of the antibody conjugates and again
this is what's really like this is
another really nice feature you can
export it as a spreadsheet or a pdf so
you can order it straight away
some people can order directly in your
cart if you wanted to or you can again
give this spreadsheet to your purchasing
officer to order it straight away
and the final panel will include all the
selected products the placeholder
reagents and any other reagents that you
want and plus for a um
for the conventional cytometer you'll
also see this spectral viewer tool which
will allow you to see really this the
special spillover for each one of these
fluorophores that you've picked
so
in terms of panel design with
fluorophore dies
um
what i have been doing is putting all
the fluorophores out of sorry putting
all the markers into the flow cytometry
panel builder
we've identified all the markers with
minimal available conjugates and as i
said what's nice about the the panel
builder is that these will be listed
from top down so those that only have
three available conjugates will be
listed at the top and those with 12
available conjugates will be listed
towards the bottom
this is good because you can assign
these first to things that are
available then i would always again
identify these markers with these low
expression met levels
and again you'll know that from
doing a lot of your reading with all of
your um
with all of uh you know to determine
your expression levels of each markers
within your cell type
i'll always assign these to the bright
floral swords first
um and then the nice thing about this is
then i would add an overflow dyes
particularly on on lineage markers
because that's what's available right
now as direct conjugates
and then match the remaining markers
with the available fluorophores
depending on antigen density and
brightness
it is a bit of work in progress but this
is certainly the way that we can create
a paddle with no before dives and we're
happy to help you with this as well
so
in summary the question is what can you
do with nova floor dyes
and really there's two things that we
can do
and i've showed show that in this
presentation first is that we can
actually do a panel upgrade we can add
additional markers or we can take some
of those troublesome fluorophores out of
the um
out of the panel and replace it with a
fluorophore with a slimmer spectrum
to reduce the complexity of these panels
we can do that with panel upgrades
what we can also do is that we can look
at broader or
deeper immunophenotyping and i'd like to
point out there is another la bruce
presentation that you can see
uh that was given
um by sudden thomas last
month
on the good and bad and the uglier 45
color panel design where she goes into
talking about higher dimensional slow
cytometry and what works and what
doesn't work and what's best to maintain
your biologic biological resolution so i
would recommend going and finding that
if you're interested in broader or
deeper immunophenotyping
finally
this is my summary
i read right clean as the new bright for
a long time
brighter is better has been the mantra
for panel design um
as you increase the amount of
markers in your flow panels this is not
holding through at all in fact brighter
will work against you if you're looking
at brighter floors on high antigen
density markers and so you really need
to be able to balance your panel
and balance them with a cleaner spectral
um a cleaner a fluorophore with a
cleaner spectra and this is what nova
floors are able to offer you
they were they are able to increase the
size of these flow panels and decrease
the spillover and spreading which also
then
increases the biological resolution
when with that i'd like to finish my
talk i'd love to hear some um
some questions from the audience if you
have any thank you very much
thank you catherine for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for let's get started our
first question is
will there be any issues when using uh
dna viability markers and nova floors
thanks good question um not sure that we
addressed it earlier but
dna viability markers will have an issue
yes
these are dna based products and so any
kind of any kind of intercalating dyes
that are going to bind to dna are going
to react with the nova floors and so we
do not recommend using anything like
your propidium iodide for instance or
any other intercalating dyes what we do
recommend is using
an amine based
uh
amine based um
live dead stain for instance like your
your
in vitrogen live dead dyes these are the
best ones to use with naval floors
so a question that we get pretty often
catherine uh what is the size of the
phyton
um good question thanks anson so the
cycle itself
is actually a really um stable structure
it is about 20 dollars in um
across and about 150
sorry 20 nanometers across and 150
kilodaltons in size so the size is about
the same as your antibody
um and so one thing that again i didn't
address is that
for all of our direct conjugates we can
actually guarantee that there
that there is a one-to-one phyton to
antibody ratio which means actually you
can use these
these fluorophores
to quantify the amount of antigens on
your cell surface and i'm pretty sure
there's not many fluorophores that are
that are quantifiable as well around
there at the moment so it's kind of an
extra added bonus for the nova floors
the other thing that is interesting
about the the structure is that
it holds
because it's a dna structure
it actually holds the fluorophores in
place and in fact it's hydrophobic so it
it actually stabilizes the fluorophores
what this means is it's incredibly
stable um
both at room temperature and in certain
fixatives so it can be used um so you
know can can be sent to australia for
instance
at room temperature for two weeks and
also it
can be used with a number of different
fixatives and we're investigating these
as live further as well
so again we want to encourage questions
from the audience uh you can just write
your question right in the q a box
i'm
going along the lines of what you just
said about stability so i think there's
a lot of documented evidence about the
stability issues that some tandem dies
have
with these nova 4 dies are they tandem
dyes can you talk a little bit more
about that
good question anson
um never floor dyes aren't tandem dyes
um so but
by the definition of tandem dyes um
they're they're
things like pe
um size 7 or or apc
7
um where
they're actually held together by a
covalent bond
um conversely
and then they use those spreading
technologies so the fretting technology
to be able to emit in a different
detector than um than the the primary
um
fluorophore
motor floors use the fretting technology
so they utilize a combination of
different dyes and they spread off each
other to be able to
to emit in one particular
predefined detector
but because they're actually held in
this
dna structure quite rigidly they don't
have the same kind of
issues that
tandem dyes have in terms of
stability you know
i'm pretty sure everyone's had
had a problem with apc size 7 where the
size 7 drops off because the covalent
bond doesn't last very long in in
fixative solutions or doesn't last very
long over a long period of time
you don't have those issues and with
nova floors they're actually highly
stable and they don't drop off and so
this this means that you can use them
over longitudinal studies you can also
use them again um
in a number of different fixatives and
buffers and we have tied a number of
different ones as well
awesome
uh yeah so we we've definitely tested
the noble floors and para formaldehyde
as well as formalin and we have not seen
any effect on fluorescence so that's
pretty cool
question from the chat
can i use note 4 dyes on seismic cube 8
flow cytometer
yes you can use nova floor dyes on any
flow cytometer
so long as they have
particular detectors that
would be able to detect
then overflow dies and
i actually don't know the the the
configuration of a seismic
cubate flow cytometer but i'm pretty
sure there are particular detectors on
there that we can that that we'll be
able to use no before diet as you as i
said we have
19 18 19 of these nova floors
um just slotting into various different
detectors in the spectral space and some
i'm pretty sure there is somewhere where
in that in that flowchart another way we
can actually use another floors so yeah
no problem
yeah absolutely as long as you have a
either a blue a yellow green or a red
laser you should be there's something
that you could definitely use i should
have said that thanks anson
um this is a really good one do nova
floors generally eliminate the need to
do compensation if compensation is still
needed does it need to be performed on
every new batch of antibodies just like
with tandem dies it is a good question
and actually
i mean answer maybe you can help me with
this but i would always recommend to do
that nova floors do not eliminate the
need to do compensation this is good
practice i would always recommend you
need to do compensation for every die
however because they're a lot more
stable
you can probably
how do i say this you could probably
guaran you can probably
see that nova floors
will perform
the same from batch to batch unlike
tandem dies you don't have that huge
variability
this is not to say you need to stop
compensation i would always recommend
doing compensation but you can expect a
less variability with nova floor diets
and so what do you what do you think
about that yeah you you pretty much
nailed it so
as far as compensation that's just going
to be based on the spectral properties
and it's really going to depend on your
panel um if you have
more than four fours
you're almost certainly going to need to
do at least a little bit of compensation
and compensating nova floors is super
easy because they are so consistent uh
with best practices i would probably say
at least for your first few experiments
still
perform your compensation with a
with each new batch of antibodies or
each new lot however we have found that
our lots a lot consistency is
super super high our lots lot
variability is less than five percent so
tandems often have a lot of variability
so you absolutely have to perform a
different compensation control for each
lot with the nova floors you could
almost certainly get away with just
doing it one time because the lights are
so consistent with each other
yes but i wouldn't recommend it how does
that sound
i'd always recommend you know performing
some kind of titration on every batch
all right there we go uh is there a plan
to make nova floors excited by the
violet laser
good question
yes we have uh plans to make no floors
excited i probably didn't go into too
much detail we only have narrow floors
at the moment for the red the blue and
yellow green lasers at the moment and
we're filling in the spectral spaces
in
on those laces as well
but
we are actually working on violet and uv
as well
i don't believe they're going to be
released this year but we certainly have
plans to release some next year
so watch this space how does that sound
very close on the the violet especially
in the uv i think those will be coming
probably early next year
all right again we've got a few more
minutes so any more questions from the
audience please feel free to drop those
into the the q a chat
um
question that i have so there's
new floors coming out and with each new
floor it seems like there's a new buffer
do nova4s have any special buffers that
need to be used with them and do other
buffers that are maybe not related to
nova floors have any impact on the nova
floors themselves
good question
so as i presented in the presentation
nova floors do require the use of a
monocyte macrophage buffer
um
because nova floors
bind non-specifically or can bind on
specifically to monocytes and
macrophages in the same way that your pe
or apc tendons do
we always recommend using the cell
blocks buffer
with nova floors
to reduce this non-specific binding what
this also does is also reduces the
background incredibly for nova floor so
i'd always recommend using that cell
block buffer with every node floor
um
it they what what's easy about this is
that the the nova floor buffer so the
cell blocks buffer can easily be added
to say your antibody master mix
just before you're adding this antibody
master mix to your cells alternatively
you can also add add it directly to the
cells if you want to but we recommend
we've had better results adding it to
the antibody master mix
saying that
cell blocks buffer can be used in
conjunction with
most if not all buffers
on the market things like your fc block
or your super bright binding buffer or
your any other you know proteins or
buffers that happen to be used on the
market we've tested most of them not all
of them but we've tested most of them
and it seemed to have absolutely no
effect so it can be easily used the
other thing is that the cell blocks
buffer can be used
um as a
replacement for your other
for your other like monocyte and
macrophage buffers like the truth stain
so
um
we one final thing about cell blocks is
that we include a
vial of cell blocks buffer in every
single nova floor sold to make sure that
these are used with the nova floors we
want to make sure that you actually get
the best um the best results out of them
and so
you will have a spare
buffer included with every number floor
yeah it's really nice if there's
something that doesn't need to be
purchased separately
are there plans to offer more antibodies
with nova floor dyes at different
brightness levels
that's a good question
uh i believe there is
um
anson and did you want to answer that
yeah that's definitely going to be one
of our areas of future focus uh right
now we're really
hammering hard on the violet and uv but
in the in the near future i suspect we
will definitely have
more floors with variable brightness
okay
would the size of phyton conjugated
antibody have any problem in the
detection of intracellular proteins
good question i'm loving your questions
i'm sorry um
would the size of phyton
um conjugate antibodies have any
problems in the detection of
intracellular proteins the answer is no
because in fact the size is again as
about as big as an antibody
and if you have a look at that in
conjunct in relation to say the size of
say a p or a p dazzle
um it's incredible
there's no there's no problem there
whatsoever so p or p does is going to be
much bigger and you can still use those
in intracellular um
in cellular experiments and so size
doesn't matter what is interesting
though with intracellular
work and in fact we are currently
optimizing our intracellular processes
is that um
there requires a little bit of blocking
in order to block your any non-specific
binding of the phyton to any kind of dna
binding or histones that i happen to be
intracellular um inside the cell and so
we are working on a protocol at the
moment we do have a few successes
in fact anthem was telling me about his
successes just this morning um
on intracellular work and we are
currently defining the protocol for this
at the moment so
watch this space yes the answer to that
question really is yes never floors can
be used for inserter and we are coming
up with an optimized protocol shortly
yeah absolutely the the number four
itself is about the size of an antibody
and the
the antibody floor conjugate is still
smaller than pe so
can absolutely be used for intracellular
the blocking is a little bit different
from a standard intracellular protocol
and we don't have that release yet but
if you have questions about that you can
definitely
shoot me an email
and i think we have time for one more
question
so
going back to the cell blocks that you
were talking about it's a monocyte and
macrophage blocking buffer
is it also an fc block
no
let's just say no it doesn't block your
fc
receptors
but you can use it with an fc block
so um
so if you have for
yeah you can use it in
in conjunction with your fc block so
um
depending on the protocol you can add it
before or after you add the ufc block
and also as i said can be used with a
number of different other buses as well
yeah if you're looking at monocytes and
macrophages you will still need to
include fc block
all right thank you catherine do you
have any final comments for our audience
um
certainly if you wanted to look at never
floors in comparison to other
fluorophores there is a great table
online i probably didn't mention it in
the in the talk but there is a fabulous
table online
if you just kind of google nova floors
comes up with
the website um
the thermo fisher website the fabulous
table that compares
separation indices of a number of
different dies along with nova floors
and so you can see the relative
brightness of nova floors in relation to
other fluorophores you can also see
again where they fit into the spectral
space as well
if you're interested in panel design we
can help you with this as well um so
contact your local
demo representative and they can
assist you with this
um
and if you have any other questions
please by all means
refer these to your local than my
representatives thank you very much for
your time i really appreciate it it's
been lovely
all right thank you again catherine for
your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor thermo fisher
scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we do not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye